[музыка]
в этом мире где с каждым днём мы всё
более связаны технологиями мы часто
забываем о том что наша истинная свобода
лежит за пределами ограничений
повседневной жизни сидя дома мы часто
смотрим в окно мечтая о приключениях и
незабываемых
[музыка]
путешествиях
[аплодисменты]
R
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
и
у нас сегодня лайтовый день Мы позволяем
людям немножечко опоздать проспать и мы
на самом деле отходим от графика на
целых 25 минут это
[музыка]
непростительно
вы поте на
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
машине
халда
сюда
[музыка]
каждое Путешествие начинается с
понимания своей миссии открыть перед
собой Новые горизонты найти своё
истинное предназначение в этом мире
знанием своей миссии мы обретаем
направление которое будет вести нас к
полноте жизни мир столь огромен и
разнообразен что нам кажется будто время
останавливается в наших руках а каждое
мгновение открывает новую
возможность
такие моменты когда мы мечтаем о
неизведанном нам предстоит не только
физическое но и внутреннее философское
путешествие чтобы понять себя и своё
место в этом
[музыка]
мире многие из нас сталкиваются с
дилеммой жить привычной нами жизнью или
собрать КЗА отправиться на поиске новых
горизонтов мы ощущаем ту притягательные
силу неизведанного оторваться от
привязанности Открыть новые культуры и
встретить незнакомцев которые станут
нашими друзьями на этом пути мы можем
развивать свои умственные навыки глубоко
погружаясь в книги и исследуя образ
веков мы можем создавать произведения
искусства позволяя своей творческой
энергии расцвести и мы можем найти
гармонию с собой и окружающим миром
воспринимая каждый миг как новое и
удивительное путешествие пути могут быть
разными иногда пересекая стены дома и
простер до горизонта открываются новые
[музыка]
возможности
не
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
успею
[музыка]
ве
[аплодисменты]
мы вместе с
[музыка]
ним
Добрый вечер всем об группы пришли да
первая вторая группа все Да итак я даю
Старт официальный Старт нашему
путешествию по Южному
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Китаю ску навити жи
ско
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
Спасибо Почему вот это важно понимать
что является ключевым ресурсом не
пытайся сделать так секрет успеха не в
бизнес
успеха что у тебя ключевой ресурс
ключевой ресурс - это то откуда твоя
сила идт ключевой фактор успеха
[музыка]
вот в поисках успеха Мы стремимся к
совершенству пытаемся догнать его но что
если истинная цель заключается не в
скорости передвижения а в мудром выборе
остановиться на пути чтобы обрести
счастливую гармонию когда мы
рассматриваем видение бизнеса как
искусства открывается Новый взгляд на
предпринимательство бизнесмен творит
свою судьбу и влияет на жизни других
людей он строит свою компанию
основываясь не только на калькуляция и
стратегиях Но и на своей интуиции
креативности и эмоциональном интеллекте
как художники мы должны быть открытыми к
экспериментам и инновациям чтобы
создавать настоящий
прорыв Если вы супер эффективны должен
быть период когда вы крайне
неэффективными делами занимаетесь А если
вы там любое там напряжены нужно чтобы
расслабленный по период то есть мы
всегда у нас вот эти крайности всегда
работают против нашей жизни каждый путь
индивидуален каждая ошибка уникальна
только через ошибки мы узнаём
непрекращающийся ценность опыта и
уверенность в своей способности
преодолевать препятствия через неудачи
Мы учимся и растём открываем новые
возможности и находим своё уникальное
место в мире без ошибок мы не могли бы
достичь мудрости и опыта которые
формирует нас как личностей
Однако успех не всегда сопровождается
счастьем мы часто забываем что счастье -
это не только внешние показатели
финансовые благополучия репутации или
материальные достижения счастье - это
состояние души гармония внутреннего мира
истинное счастье достигается через
самосознание раскрытие своего потенциала
и вклад в благо
общества Ну хорошо давайте
[аплодисменты]
похлопаем
Ну что же Пойдёмте друзья
[музыка]
мои Сколько по времени ли вырезать
а мы находимся на южной оконечности
Великой Китайской стены эту стену нашли
не так давно Она строилась 100 лет она
проходит по горам здесь Проживает народы
смио и ханьцы защищались от этой
народности потому что они жили в горах и
постоянно нападали на хаце длина стены
214 м строилась она 100 лет и она редко
посещаемое здесь не так много туристов
все в основном едут в Пекин А интересно
было посмотреть эту часть Китайской
стены Привет меня зовут Геннадий Я
предприниматель из Москвы Меня зовут
Янис Ассалям алейкум всем Здравствуйте
меня зовут
ахтари Сегодня мы смотрим большую
китайскую Южную стену в Китае я был
раньше но правда давно 10 лет назад
впечатления очень хорошие потому что
подобного я не видел никогда да как
всегда как любое путешествие маргулана
это что-то новое что-то необычное то
чего ты ещё 100% никогда не видел
вчерашний день был хороший мы целый день
провели разборы Это был шикарнейший
разбор разбор который начался с одного
был перевёрнут на 180° и пришли мык
совершенно к другому то есть мы
совмещаем и путешествие и бизнес и
полезности разборы очень интересные как
всегда маргулана какие-то инса получили
мы разобрали вчера три кейса очень
подробно Ребята получили огромную пользу
и те кого разбирали и те кто слушали
собственно что происходит здесь ребята
приходят с одним запросом и
мугун своим профессионализмом и опытом
даёт ту информацию которая их заставляет
задуматься и предположить что возможно
Есть другой способ прийти к тому
результату который они хотят несколько
лет назад в интернете видел человека
который выражает свои мысли идеи и они
очень схожи с моими вообще настолько
одинаково думаем настолько мы одинаково
Подходим к решению каких-то вопросов
взгляды мнения поэтому я и согласился
поэтому захотел приехать сюда в Китай
чтобы увидеть этого человека встретиться
познакомиться пообщаться сегодня
Допустим мы на китайской стене прошлый
наш выезд был это коно пеший тур Где мы
жили в условиях о которых мы даже
представить не могли но получили
удовольствие столько который ты не
получаешь путешествия когда ты едешь в
Турцию в Египет там или ещ в
какую-нибудь любую другую страну
[музыка]
да
потому что оче
нела очень
[музыка]
очень
надо было спорить с кем-то лест у есть
Тая лестница Здоров там ступенек 800 с
чем-то
Так что Ну все
взошли друзья мы забрались на Южную
Китайскую стену посмотри какая красота
вокруг просто невероятно я понимаю
почему они эти земли защищают сда Да
хочет Приветствую Меня зовут Станислав Я
из Барселоны занимаюсь открытием
автосервисов по всему миру Так мы на
китайской стене враження типа супер
Слава Украине Меня зовут Ренат город
Бешкек рзн астов Алексей Сергеевич я
нахожусь на Великой Китайской стене Я
думал что ВС зроблено в 16 ро но Ока
реставрация таке враження хожу воно там
видов ми молоточками ВС рне угли но з
другого боку враження ВХ сооружений спод
дуже класно сегодня наме я сдела ещ одну
зю
сегодня сбылась моя мечта я увидел
Великую Китайскую стену и даже где она
заканчивается слушайте кайф и вчера и
сегодня буря эмоций это же мечта всех
наших поколений попасть на эту Китайскую
стену посмотреть что же в Китае творится
и вот мы здесь дякую за повестку марула
И всем
привет Ой какая кра А вы знали что в
Китае очень уважают жен на самом
де королевы для женщин здесь делают всё
И вот эти вот замечательные цветочки это
настоящие их здесь плетут старые бабушки
которые сидят везде и дарят потом тем
кто здесь приходит в гости Вот так о
вчерашний день Это же были бизнес
разборы от Марго алиевича вчера за
несколько разборов Я получил очень много
инсайтов то есть разбирают другого
человека ты понимаешь всё про себя да то
есть разные бизнесы но принцип и система
везде одна и та же сегодня мы на
завтраке это обсуждали и у всех просто
взрыв все уже горят руки чешутся руки
горят глаза гово Сейчас мы вернёмся И
начнём делать то что мы уже получили Как
говорит маргулан это внедрять То есть я
быстро послушал тут же позвонил
помощнику Ассистенту и говорю делаем
делаем делаем благодаря одному разбору
построил целую стратегию на Ближайшие 5
лет ты получаешь на выходе запакованный
результат плюс план действий для меня
это было подтверждение тем что я на
правильном пути по бизнесу и сегодня уже
они мне пишут вот уже есть результаты Да
как бы как-то так это сильные разборы и
сильные люди здесь собрана команда
которая понимают друг друго на все на
одном уровне А ещё впереди у нас 5-6
дней которые будут наполнены такими
событиями И я очень рад что впереди у
нас ещё огромное количество
[музыка]
времени
раздватри
и А теперь на счёт три все на меня бежим
[аплодисменты]
2Т
[музыка]
е
[аплодисменты]
сажают рассаду вот в рядок удобрение
внесли
вон всё дождик пойдёт он приживётся и
огонь будет Меня зовут Кайрат Айдаров Я
занимаюсь
пестицидами ВС чистенько е сначала
получается Пли должна быть где-то у них
есть теплица где они эту рассаду
разводят Ну болеет мальца уж что теперь
сделаешь
Вот это получается афо то есть он что
делает почвообработка рыхление Вот это
проводит на там условно 15 см Дальше они
рукопашные грядки нарезают тяжёлый труд
вчерашняя прогулка сегодняшняя да На вот
Китайскую стену Мы же привыкли к тому
что в новостях какие-то инфраструктурные
ве Китая какието Китая Для нас это как
бы о мы там восторга всем этим Приехав
сюда Я понял что за всем этим стоит
очень такой кропотливый тяжёлый труд
если вот история этой Китайской стены Да
какой-то участок в 191 км они строили
около 120 лет это Ну на самом деле
достойно уважения Ну ещё раз
подчёркивает что какие-то достойные
реально результата они достигаются не
быстро а путём долгого и кропотливого
труда
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
по у
нада
е
зата знаете Во вот то что вы
делаете мужчины гадают У кого в
следующем году ребнок
родится если попадёшь сколько раз лько
родится у меня один ребнок
[музыка]
за дружбу
народа
О смотри курице сидит яйце
на Я очень рад что поехал в эту поездку
первый раз на таком мероприятии и хочу
сказать что я в восторге а Добрый день я
В путешествии Великолепном путешествии с
и его Командо поездка в Китай меня очень
сильно вдохновляет Здесь люди очень
отзывчивы к туристам для них туристы это
какой-то экспириенс да они приветливые
также не удивляйтесь Если вы Посетите
Китай они будут с вами фотографироваться
и это необычайно и невероятно красивое
путешествие потому что у нас есть всё и
разборы и очень вкусная еда и очень
интересные люди которые здесь собрались
в команду я как бы представляла себе что
я получу очень много подпитки да
эмоционально Но вот за вот эти дня мой
мозг уже кипит так то есть он работает
на все 1000% потому что от полученной
информации я сразу начала думать куда
что как как мне применить что мне
поменять Я понимаю что в команду не
собираются люди просто так они
собираются по определённым интересом они
могут друг друга наполнить друг другу
помо онь важно Если у меня будет
возможность то я буду сюда приезжать я
буду общаться с успешными людьми я буду
общаться с людьми которые хотят
развиваться с которыми у нас схожие
ценности в жизни Почему я вообще поехал
в эту поездку потому что мне нравится
мышление Орлан кальви я сам люблю
развиваться Потому что когда ты
развиваешься ты Мир Совершенно
по-другому видишь мы познаём очень много
важных вещей которые меняют нашу картину
мира меняют наше сознание дают нам
продвижение А мы всегда хотим двигаться
Мы всегда хотим чтобы было вокруг
красиво и мы всегда хотим счастья а где
есть счастье а счастье есть у нас и то
что мы излучаем это и есть счастье а те
люди которые вокруг нас собираются это
те масса счастливых людей которые
умножают Наше счастье в разы Ну и
конечно вся команда ну просто супер Так
что спасибо огромное что я
здесь
ну
Мне кажется вы ему заплатили Да за то
чтобы
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
онл
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
а
[музыка]
класс 15
минут я потому что моя тема я
[музыка]
Ува
Я посмотрю
по
[музыка]
мы находимся в Китае проходим по ули по
улицам Мы вот только что пообедали
Поужинали точнее в ресторане и теперь
смотрим улицы окрест города Да мы были в
трёх городах и вот именно культурную
часть получается вот здесь
увидеть нжл например ногие надписи
магазины или ещё таблички там там уже
был английский перевод А тут ходишь и
уже вообще ничего не понимаешь Ну и
круто вот Ну видно город Старый люди вот
здешние местные и Ну разница
[музыка]
большая
заработаем
[музыка]
you
пи
[музыка]
Так давай держите кто
будет Давай
[музыка]
давай это после грибов
коро
о весь сок весь сок выпускаешь шка её
прямо как шашлык надо ши
О О Господи ну что
пробуем я видео снимала
это Как
ощущения скор проиграл
просто то чтобы по вкусу Вкусно но по
сути Вкусно
[музыка]
да
L
[музыка]
когда
мы
[музыка]
т
Посмотрите
налево
D
а копались скажи
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
да за
законо
й
[музыка]
Si
Si s
[музыка]
S
[аплодисменты]
Добрый день дорогие друзья сегодня будет
у нас офигенный экстрим
потому самы высоких точек по прыжкам в
Китае это мост экстрима стеклянный мост
сегодня будет прыжок
банн это самая высокая бан дмн в мире в
общем я в предвкушении очень боюсь всю
жизнь боялся Не разу не прыгал как раз
по этому поводу но тут самая высокая
точка Я закрою этот гельштат причём два
раза два раза я приду на мост и там уже
решу посмотрю на участников Как они
прыгают что Уменя было меньше страха
будеть так можно е прыгать и лазить Ну
можно на лазить лучше будем
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
лазить как вам не страшно чуть-чуть
чуть-чуть
что не
страшно Ну что
разминаемся Пока
нормально Да посмот один вот так а
второй опять же
так если вы сильно волну друзья
вперёд ребята ждите новостей первое
предложение Бен джампинг - это
небезопасно да
даже заполняя эту бумажку всё равно
волнуешься шесть человек прыгает раз в
30 минут Окей сейчас между собой Мы
должны решить Кто следующий шесть
[музыка]
человек
блин реально страшно
Прикинь у меня это улыбка
естественная Во что я вписался ребята
о Нихрена
себе Вот это тема Ну ниче Это Китай
детка Made in чай намаза вот самое
главное ребята Это вниз не смотреть вот
так вот ни в коем случае не делай если
вот так вот то вообще не стоит делать А
если прыгать это вообще не надо то что я
делаю Это плохо ощущения классные вообще
вид замечательный ничего такого в жизни
никогда не видел просто завораживает
даже можно вниз посмотреть что там
творится хо метров не знаю но под нами
скалы
Ну высота большая где-то около 200 м
по-моему ничего же страшного нет
правильно мы
прикреплены нас очень стабильный пол
Хотя это не
[музыка]
точно
отлично Как у вас ощущение как у
космонавта страшно Но надо эффект такой
чем страшнее потом тем больше
удовольствия
[музыка]
потом как ребята наши прыгают готовимся
устраиваемся их
Поддержи
[музыка]
Are you
ready
[музыка]
ништяк Вот
это это было охрененно самое страшное
было Это просто подойти и встать на
следы которые там на плите а потом а
потом просто доверить судьбе вот прыгнул
260 м самый высокий ба м мире порите
свои страхи не так это всё
страшно я знал что со мной всё будет в
порядке Поэтому со мной ничего не
случилось нет смелости без
страха самый самый самый самый такой
момент это когда ты стоишь
вот Доверие всё там уже летишь сначала
лаза открыл и такой
наж эмоции супер вообще поначалу было
страшно Но главное не смотреть вниз а
потом это просто такой кайф не передать
словами ощущения классные супер Мне
очень понравилось самое страшное только
шагнуть как в любом бизнесе страшно
сделать первый
шаг она прямо прыгнула ногами вниз
ногами
вниз она чуть неправильно да там
рассказывает
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
можно это снять это этим хо лицо у меня
наверно всё говорит Да обо
[музыка]
мне
О вот эта вот штука
классная
атно блин как будто каждый день так
ходила всё
[музыка]
классно
АФК Там
страшно у
ништяк кто сы тот
гибнет о аккуратно Аккуратно не норма
э тут не
высо
[музыка]
а
yeah
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
а я с ребятами общался и почему они
многие
[музыка]
боялись
Зачем Красавчики
Красавчики смешно и страшно на самом
деле полтора часа мы лазили по скалам
вверх-вниз не страшно начинаешь идти не
страшно сейчас после этого вообще ничего
не страшно главное сделать первый шаг
Господи
Нет братан Да говори сосе краси Ну
наверное на тот момент когда я там
находилась казалось что страшно сейчас
честно сказать Всем рекомендую
Здравствуйте если это ваш муж он
офигенный красавчик он так себя поборол
сегодня два раза
Молодец Это было очень страшно очень
страшно самое страшное что в моей жизни
но на самом деле пока ты не попробуешь
ты не поймёшь потому что опыт - это
может быть только твой Ты можешь
наблюдать за счёт опм но ты не можешь
его взять себе потому что это его опыт А
это мой Да реально классная штука очень
душевная немножко страш Если честно мне
было очень страшно Я думаю я сдохну мы
сделали
это Сегодня у нас день вот такой
экстремальный день классное ущелье на
самом деле я в Китае давно Ну вот здесь
первый раз сюда стоит однозначно
приехать круто тяжело было и страшно
было Я показывал чтом не было мне
страшно но страшно бы в основном Когда
это В вироку переходили там значит
отражаться Это было очень отлично Ну
каска же была но я постоянно задевал на
самом деле Да это немножко это кто
пониже тому поудобнее но у меня опыт у
меня опыт Я же по горам постоянно
поэтому Но на самом деле очень круто
очень круто есть Адреналин хороший
Адреналин такой Есть места где прям там
надо потрудиться хоть Я из Грузии гору
привык Но было сложно очень сложно Ну
спасибо за это Адреналин Всё уже
закончился кортизол закончился все
гормоны которые должны были выстрелить
всё Выстрели мы таки пришли уже нам всё
пофиг мы можем записываться в
[смех]
спецназ побежали
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
сюда
караби
[аплодисменты]
оп
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
оп вы
[музыка]
вы
arriv
смотрим и мы думаем что ты ты ты
[музыка]
ты всякие
разные
ле
Да они тебя знают все
всех странны
острова и здоровья и возможность
[музыка]
восстанавливать спокойно вообще нас не
качает ни
разум Просто классно вот прям вот вот
так же вот
так
привычку
нужно чтобы выработать привычку я не
знаю я не
[музыка]
знаю Мы сегодня на чудесной горе Тань мы
на самом высоком фуникулёре канатная
дорога по которой мы ехали 7,5 км я
каталась на канатной дороги думала что
на модере она самая большая но нет здесь
это намного выше круче и красивее было
очень страшно особенно на вот этих
переходах когда кабину трясёт это очень
сильно завораживает правда лучше гор
могут быть только горы на которых ещё не
бывал нас ждёт впереди не знаю не
смотрел программу я наслаждаюсь и кайфую
[музыка]
моментом
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
посмотрите какая
красота что тут можно сказать тут можно
просто посмотреть и всё будет и так ясно
Так что всё супер Эмоции переполняют
меня мы на самой высокой точке в Китае
насколько всё-таки это народ со своей
философией как они всё
организовывают это конечно очень очень
здорово слушайте Я в восторге на самом
деле мне очень нравится здесь безумно
красивые виды красивые горы классная
компания я получил больше чем ожидал от
этого тура А ещё я очень счастлива что
оказалась здесь с такой классной
командой с таким общест это даёт
безумную энергию и знаете Это просто
счастье находиться в окружении таких
людей Огромное спасибо за этот тур Я
просто очень
[музыка]
счастлива
сделаем встречу выпускников потом
сделаем эту встреча возможно нам надо
просто вместе захотеть и всё произойдёт
правильно Если серьёзно если мы не
нарыва было очень приятно конечно со
всеми людьми познакомиться Я думал так я
думаю чисто вот там похожу тут погуляю и
всё думаю достаточно и что-то само так
раз и захотелось и мне в принципе вообще
все понравились первые дни все были
как-то там Скованные сдержанные сейчас
все открылись показали себя Ну очень
круто Что Все сейчас сдружились стали
такие вот единственно как одна команда
одна маленькая большая семья Вот как раз
тут собрались такие люди которые не
только про деньги а которые просто про
жизнь про желание своего сердца желание
своей души Круто было с каждым
пообщаться раз здесь находиться И на
самом деле это была моя мечта и она
осуществилась это как раз про то что всё
у нас в голове золотые слова
Да спасибо
[музыка]
все
друзья Всем привет Меня зовут Виталик я
из города Риги я сейчас занимаюсь тем
что путешествую по миру и на своём
примере показываю людям что можно идти
духовным путём и при этом не обламывать
в материальном мире в целом путешествие
очень очень очень энергично очень
радостно Я очень много что пережил в
этом мире и меня достаточно сложно
удивить но Китай он меня удивляет каждый
день это ну невероятное место совсем
другое е кто-то не посещал его
обязательно Посетите если есть что-то о
чём я желаю в этой жизни что я не сделал
этого раньше вообще незабываемые
впечатление очень много чего интересного
увидели горы неописуемой красоты Очень
красиво Очень канатная дорога
Великолепная
7500 метров это впечатляет поднимаешься
над каньоном красота внизу пропасть и
извилистая дорога где 99 поворотов
получаю тут заряд счастья энергии именно
от сообщества от коллектива от того
концентрата людей так подобрался такой
концентрат людей которые все излучают
энергию делится и тут настолько
разностная публика собралась с разными
интересами куча людей у которых также
совпадают цели с моими и я рад вообще
Принимать во всём этом участии это
вообще была моя мечта буду очень рад ещё
увидеться со всеми ребятами с которыми
подружились в следующих шествиях Скучать
не буду по той причине что с многими
людьми мы уже обменялись контактами
поддерживать Я думаю мы даже вместе
что-то сделаем большое классное полезное
всему
[музыка]
миру даже в этих горах сделали огромный
эскалатор два марша один был марш
покороче сейчас огромный длинный
эскалатор как в метро
[музыка]
спускаемся во врата которые разделяют
небо и землю будем
смотреть
я да мы сейчас находимся на горе
особенность этой горы в том что она
километр 100 м и сплошная Скала просто
стена в этой огромной скале существует
Вот такая дыра которая называется
Небесные ворота сейчас пешком Идём по
ступенькам по лестнице 999
ступеней
смотри смотря Дале
вперёд
[музыка]
зала
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
стоял Лика
[аплодисменты]
бан
[музыка]
так как сегодня не устали
Нормально как день прошёл Отлично Да мне
тоже сегодня день понравился такой с
точки
зрения
видов конечно шикарно такая нереальная
сюрреалистичная картина была даже не
похоже что это в реальности прямо так
очень необычная природа очень просто
необычная в нашем стремлении к успеху и
счастью мы задаём вопросами о смысле
жизни и нашем месте во Вселенной Мы
погружаемся в философию размышляя о
природе реальности и нашей способности
воспринимать Мир вокруг нас увидеть
гармонию в хаосе найти равновесие в
несовершенстве не забывать что наш
главный актив - это не только
материальные или финансовые ресурсы но и
наша способность быть здоровыми
свободными и воспринимать мир во всей
его красоте и
сложности большинство бизнесменов путают
вот эти два стула это два разных стула
стул бизнесмена стул инвестора бизнесмен
хорошо зарабатывает на своём бизнесе и
постоянно теряет на инвестициях потому
что там его друг пригласил он проверо
попа там Он подумал что будет хорошая
инвестиция проинвестировать попал и
получается вот у него есть дойная корова
он на этом зарабатывает молоко отдаёт
другим а те ни фига приплод не приносят
бизнесмен хочет заработать много а
инвестор хочет в первую очередь
сохранить деньги а вообще в жизни
существуют беговые дорожки первая
дорожка - это дорожка финансов вы
бегаете дорожку финансов вот я пробежал
до ЛР 6 млрд заработал и вот меня точно
не тянет по второму кругу бежать по этой
дорожке соответственно Я перешёл на
вторую дорожку вторая дорожка называется
Слава я бегу по второй дорожке сейчас у
меня подписчики известность и так далее
это драйви но другой вопрос мне дравит
не просто Слава сама по себе А мне Слава
нравится как Побочный продукт моей
пользы обществу например до этого я
деньги зарабатывал как Побочный продукт
моей эффективности успех и счастье - это
не цель достижени которые требуют и бега
и остановки и открытие разных аспектов
мира в котором мы живём позволяет нам
стать Не только успешными но и
счастливыми Спасибо ребята всем
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
спасибо
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
ё
[музыка]
to
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
же
скажем со эти
помидоры
[музыка]
природ друя друзья несколько кадро
Фантастическая
снимаете
[музыка]
а мы сейчас находимся в Национальном
парке чанд в котором находится гора
Аватара вот сзади меня уже открывается
виды сейчас мы гуляем вдоль всех
смотровых площадок Я прямо выучил как он
называется парк Джан дн У меня такое
впечатление как будто я в каком-то
фильме это уже видел уже какое-то такое
ощущение не реальности Ты ощущаешь что
ты вот в этом фильме В каком-то другом
фильме неважно там это Аватар или что-то
подобное Но это окружающая Красота
вокруг Она навевает на тебя такие
хорошие мысли идеи я пока прогулялся по
парку у меня столько возникло
благодарности невероятный парк очень
нравится обзорные площадки шикарные аж
захотелось пересмотреть Аватар на
природе это ещё мощнее выглядит и я в
восторге вообще От этого от этого
зрелище и как природа насколько Красиво
сделала это место недаром наш тур
называется путешествие по сказочному
Китаю и это действительно оказалось так
сегодняшний день для ня бы насыщенный
самый интересный и где я для себя взяла
очень много таких вещей которые говорят
о том что у нас полностью весь мир
наполнен красивыми вещами сказочными
вещами и это место одно из них для меня
это был сегодня один из самых
впечатляющих дней в этом году можно
сказать впечатление не передать словами
задаю вопросы себе как как вообще могло
такое создаться кто это Бог природа ну
непонятно Да и здесь очень можно просто
стать и стоять несколько часов смотреть
на Эти прекрасные горы и думать об этом
и больше нени о чем экскурсии Аватор
очень-очень Круто И эти красота мне
очень-очень впечатлил очень красивое
место я не знаю это входит в семь чудес
света если даже не входит надо его
включить туда Ну горы реально
потрясающие и одна особенность в том что
на этих гох растут сосны они все прямо в
соснах что очень даже удивительно наши
непрерывно ускоряющие время часто
исчезает важное проживание каждого
момента наслаждение тишиной Погружение в
самих себя мы забываем о том что именно
здесь и сейчас мы обретаем нашу жизнь и
именно эти мгновения определяют Наше
счастье главное Не упустить свою жизнь
не забыть остановиться задуматься и
вдохнуть глубоко открыть для себя
радость из присутствия любить искусство
совершенствовать то что мы
[музыка]
любим мы купили ленточку чтобы завязать
желание мы коне не знаем что тут
написано но верим в торим в то
что
что тно что нано наше желание которое
сейчас мы загадаем и завяжем Ну мы так
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
верим
ма
ка
давай я говорю на он на
постоян
закончи Вот это
косяк здесь есть такое поверье
загадываешь желание выбрасываешь рыбку в
пруд отпускаешь Я загадываю желание
Чтобы поскорее во всём нашем мире
восстановился баланс и чтобы уровня силы
зла силы добра и нашли свою точку
нулевую чтобы всё стало у нас хорошо и
спокойно Давай
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
рыбка
с
[музыка]
Сегодня у нас завершающий заключающий
день в Китае Как тебе Сердце говорит
блин чувак Спасибо тебе что ты меня сюда
привёз так хорошо Меня ещ никогда не
было и подряд на протяжении почти семи
или там ми дней я даже потерял счёт
столько информации Столько эмоций самое
главное и Спектр этих эмоций от
удивления до озарения у нас собралась
такая компания которая все идут на одной
волне это бы про шикарная
встре радился нано что мы все совпа по
интересам ребята которые здесь собрались
они решают не только свою личную
какую-то задачу из этой задачи они уже
вышли они уже вышли на тот уровень когда
они решают задачи масс людей выходит на
такой серьёзный уровень на котором уже
личные приоритеты уже все закрыты
наверное у всех у нас есть огромное
количество
вопросов наружу сформировались самое
главное были полученные ответы когда
находишься в таком кругу людей любые
твои задачи они очень быстро решаются на
раз-два для меня поиск решения этой
задачи она могла бы занять Ну месяц два
три может быть даже и год а другие
ребята Они уже прошли через эти задачи
соответственно они находят Решение вот
так вот по щелчку пальцу Огромное
спасибо огромное Спасибо всем тем людям
которые окружали меня на протяжении вот
этого наше Великолепного путешествии
которые искренне отдавали своё тепло
свои знания свою любовь свою обратную
связь Я тоже старался обратно всё это
вернуть супер супер спасибо спасибо на
самом деле вот прям чувствую сердцем что
как будто бы уже уже мне кого-то не
хватает уже мне хочется снова с кем-то
Пообщаться мы уже стали друг другу
близки настолько как одна семья даже
расставаться не охота охота как бы
дальше с ними идти на одной волне
поэтому я не знаю завтра как мы будем со
всеми прощаться это наверное будут слёзы
Обнимашки целовашки дальше продолжение
Всех любим Всех ём Казахстане
наверное
Вот и подошла к концу наше
путешествие 9 дней закончилось
мгновенно это было что-то незабываемое
[музыка]
для
та таком
формате бизнес разборы с
путешествием новые
знакомство для меня это было очень
[музыка]
классно
лефон
а у меня О я даже не знаю что сказать
очень приятно с одной стороны с другой
стороны очень жаль улетать Ну так всегда
всегда всё хорошее
кончается Я люблю вас благодарю Вас хочу
вас снова
видеть Спасибо
что я вам хочу сказать когда я прыгала у
меня так ноги руки не трусили как
сейчас я безумно рада что я приехала
сюда потому что ну этом огромное вам
спасибо то есть возвращаюсь знаете с
новыми мозгами
домой Так что ребят всё до встречи не
буду больше
продолжать
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
AS
[музыка]
есть сейчас на
телефон Всё спасибо
Хорошо всё получилось а сейчас была
общая фотография по причине того что
наши получается коллеги а уезжают Раньше
у них ночной билет ночной
самолёт Хорошего полёта ро чтоб ты
победила я вас
лю делайте
[музыка]
дальше
эти 7 дней или й я даже не считал
пролетели реально как один миг Вчера
только со всеми познакомились вчера
узнали и так быстро всё прошло Может
быть потому что было так насыщено и
насыщено было и с точки зрения внешних
впечатлений с точки зрения внутренней
работы очень
по приятные умные Мне было очень приятно
вас
разбирать мне понравилась работа команды
ещё раз подчеркну команда классная А И
вообще это то ради чего я езжу И что мне
нравится в таких путешествиях я с вами
отдыхаю душой телом Мне многие подходят
и спрашивают ну не устаёшь го я могу
устать если занимаюсь любим
делом конечно же Огромное спасибо Кави
такую возможность то что мы вот здесь
сес собрались люди с общими ценностями
совершенно разные совершенно с разных
сра необычный формат самого путешествия
мы постоянно Обсуждаем что здесь как
будто три комплектующие время
проведённое В путешествии не
засчитывается в Во время вашей жизни То
есть сейчас мы выиграли себе е 89 дней
плюсом нашей жизни люди никогда не
возвращаются там где
плохо и раз мы я вот много Уже вижу
людей с которыми мы ездим постоянно то
есть раз количество постоянных желающих
возрастает Это говорит о том что здесь
очень хорошо я многому научился у всех
вас каждый зарядил меня позитивной
энергией поэтому спасибо большое марн
коневич всей команде ребятам Я очень
рада знакомству с Вами Спасибо вам всем
Приезжайте в Алмату поэтому Давайте
дальше продолжать вре обща у каждого
своя боль свой бизнес поэтому обмен это
Дат очень много энергии Мы друг у друга
наполняем Огромное спасибо всем кто
принимал участие в этом всём всем
ребятам Кто приехал все вообще безумно
классные Ребята с разных стран Я очень
благодарен очень доволен что я здесь и
знаю что
случайно конда организация супер Ну и
все вы ребята просто хорошие я вас
просто всех
люблю
друзья Всем спасибо Для меня честь быть
в вашем обществе и отдельно хочу
поблагодарить каждого потому что у
каждого я чему-то
научился каждый по-своему
уникален каждый по-своему
является примером для подражания поэтому
ребята Спасибо вам огромное Давайте
видеться чаще давайте дружить Давайте
расти вместе
[аплодисменты]
спасибо наш мир полон удивительных
явлений магии и непостижимой красоты
самое главное - это не забывать о том
что в каждом мгновении скрыта мудрость и
глубокий смысл способности видеть
красоту Мы открываем дверь в мир полный
возможностей и
[музыка]
впечатлений